well lots of officials from towns near
the border are not too happy about the
doj saying it will appeal the judge's
ruling to keep title 42 in place my next
guest is one of them Don Mclaughlin Jr
is the Republican mayor of Vivaldi Texas
uh mayor thank you for being here you
know even with title 42 we had 234
thousand migrant Encounters in April I
mean that's just such a huge number it's
it's close to 3 million a year uh
imagine doubling that is that what we
would have if you got rid of 42
uh double or triple it I mean you know
we've heard it uh he showed you the
video of Reynosa we've heard over
Imperial stegos is a camp of over 18 to
20 000 over there waiting to cross so so
I mean what are you guys going to do I
mean you've got a limited amount of
resources uh the federal government has
again has not been handling this as well
as we're sending 40 billion over to
Ukraine uh you guys could really use
some of that money here right
we could use it I mean our police
department and Sheriff's Department
yesterday alone and intercepted eight
human smuggling cases right here in
Uvalde and three Pursuits besides the
eight that we did catch I mean and this
is because our borders wide open because
our border patrol is not on the border
they've got this this Administration has
them in processing centers processing
immigrants
so the water's wide open they're just
there just aren't enough people around
to handle all this and and as you
mentioned I mean it it's not just the
Border itself where people are suffering
or although more there than anywhere
else it's it's because of fentanyl
people all over America are are
suffering because of of these these
midnight runs where where the
administration sends migrants to other
parts of the country uh and we suddenly
see a lot of people show up in our
communities I that's why I believe 63
percent of Americans think we simply
cannot get rid of title 42 at this
moment
we came and we shouldn't get rid of
title 42 we already strengthen and added
other countries to it if you look at San
Antonio where all these migrants are
going from Laredo Eagle Pass El Rio the
Del Rio sector where they're all going
to San Antonio San Antonio's covet cases
yesterday alone increased by 400. the
most since February wow I'm not saying
it all came from there but all of a
sudden we're having a surge in cases
again and look at the number of migrants
that they're sending to San Antonio
well by the way I should say mayor that
these These are live shots that we're
seeing on the left side of the screen
we're looking at Eagle Pass right now as
we're speaking uh and there it should be
emphasized by the way that this is this
is an issue that concerns Hispanic
Americans as well as everybody else I
mean it's it's in fact the the
president's approval ratings have gone
down tremendously among the Hispanic
community in the United States so it's
it's something that most Americans
really are united on in terms of a
problem that has to be fixed
I I agree that the Hispanic Community is
fed up with this we have a lot of great
Hispanics in our families in our
community and their parents came over
the right way our Sheriff's parents want
to they came over they applied for their
Green Card his parents worked and waited
eight to ten years but they finally got
their green card and and their their
story of The Americans dream that you
can come over and do it the right way
and do things but we just keep flooding
them over and over and the Hispanic
Community is fed up with it that this
Administration has no regard for for for
the rights of American citizens these
immigrants have better rights than we do
today now having said that a lot of
people even those who are are in
agreement that we have to fix the crisis
that the Border say that 42 is not a
long-term solution of course it was a
result of the pandemic it has it has
kept things from getting even more out
of control but eventually it's just a
tourniquet you have to really uh be to
have some kind of permanent solution to
the Border crisis getting back to the
remain in Mexico would that be a place
to start
it would I mean I don't know why we're
all we're all concerned about Mexico
because Mexico shared and concerned
about sending them over to the United
States we need to send them back to make
school make them wait and then when
Mexico has to deal with the large
numbers that we are maybe they'll start
shutting their southern border down and
limited these groups coming through now
mayor are you getting any support is
anybody listening inside the Beltway to
your cries for help
from Washington no nothing I mean thank
God the governor sentence extra DPS
Troopers to our area but I mean they're
here for a couple of days and then
there's a surge somewhere and they're
pulled out but like I said the the
number of bailouts the number of
Pursuits the number of of human
smuggling cases that we're seeing have
just gotten it's almost triple uh weekly
now and mayor finally what is the
economic effect on your community from
all this
well I mean you know the the economic
economic we haven't really studied that
yet but it is I mean businesses you know
are concerned uh citizens are concerned
I mean with with gas prices and
different things I mean everybody's
concerned what's going on and yet we
keep pouring all this money to these to
these migrants are coming over what
about helping our own American citizens
out what about taking some of this money
and putting it in the food programs and
so forth that where families really
needed that are struggling today yeah
well as you can see Americans are
concerned they do believe we need a a
real solution mayor McLaughlin we wish
you the very best sir thank you for
being here appreciate it